The Incredibles are back for the
brand-new teaser trailer for the super
long awaited sequel yippee-ki-yay movie
lovers it's Jan here and in this video
I'm going to break down the new teaser
the Pixar's Incredibles 2
[Music]
I'm really excited for this movie I love
the style of the animation and the score
by Michael Giacchino is just gorgeous so
I can't wait to see in here lots more of
that the way the teaser kicks off here
will feel familiar to you if you've
watched Pixar's short film
jack-jack attack where you'll have seen
the Parr family's youngest child passed
through solid objects like he does here
notice in the teaser footage that when
jack-jack can uses his laser vision it's
green whereas in jack-jack attack is
actually purple I wonder if there's a
significant reason behind that change of
color or whether the filmmakers think
this new color looks better with the
rest of the color scheme in the new
movie or perhaps most likely it's just
because the background in this teaser is
red and Jack Jackson laser vision
wouldn't have stood out as clearly
against that if they'd use purple
instead of the green color they've gone
for here I thought it was really fun the
way they use Jack Jack to create the
movie's new logo from the old one so we
see Jack Jack use his laser vision to
split the single eye to create two eyes
which is a really cool and clever way to
show visually that this is a second film
Incredibles - and it was also funny
later in the clip when he zaps his dad
splitting his hair in two down the
middle in a similar way we already saw
Jack Jack unleash a variety of
superpowers in front of his babysitter
and against the villain a syndrome in
both the first Incredibles feature film
and the short film but his parents
didn't see those powers because when
Syndrome was battling the baby high up
in the sky Jack Jack's family were on
the ground below however at the very end
of the Incredibles we did see Jack
jacked on a mask like the rest of his
family seemingly ready to do battle with
the villain the Underminer
who was voiced by Pixar's good luck
charm John Ratzenberger and that's
exactly where the new movie will pick up
-
some Incredibles - footage that screened
at d23 this summer showed Jack Jack
using his powers against a raccoon and
his father Bob waking up and cheering he
has powers and if you compare that to
this new teaser trailer it sounds a
little like this is a variation of the
end of that d23 footage I love the way
in this teaser that his father is so
proud of his sons superhero abilities
and I also loved the way that Jack Jack
seems to sneeze here which causes him to
cross through a range of his powers in a
similar way to how he seemed to hiccup
in Jack Jack attack just before he
turned into a fireball showing perhaps
that he's not in complete control yet of
all his powers it's a shame we don't get
to see the whole family in the teaser
though I'm sure we'll get to see more of
them in the first full trailer according
to writer director Brad Bird Elastigirl
will be at the forefront of the action
in the new feature while Bob Parr aka
mr. incredible has to stay home facing
his biggest challenge yet and I'm
guessing that some of that challenge
will be linked to what we've just seen
in this teaser and the revelation of
Jack Jack's superpowers so how excited
are you for Incredibles 2 and what did
you think of the teaser trailer let me
know in the comments below
make sure you subscribe and turn on your
notifications to get all my new Disney
and Pixar videos including Pixar's Koko
later this week and tap the screen right
here for more videos I'm sure you'll
enjoy thanks for watching and see you
next time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers